sur ces sujets tiens la parole et comme
monsieur serge letchimy merci monsieur
le président monsieur le premier
ministre il y as entre la république et
des peuples d'outre-mer des reliques de
l'époque coloniale qui affecte toujours
les relations humaines et nourrissent
des frictions raciale parmi ces reliques
ya la question des escarpins
géométriques
cette réserve foncière de l'époque
coloniale le long du littoral s'est
transformé au fil du temps en refuge
pour les plus pauvres mais aussi en zone
de privatisation plus ou moins abusif
entre pauvreté et richesse ne sait quand
pas font l'objet d'innombrables conflits
d'usagé
les récents événements de fond larion de
la commune de sainte luce en martinique
sont révélateurs d'un sentiment
d'injustice et d'un profond malaise qui
traverse le pays sur la question
foncière
cette situation met aussi en évidence
les carences inadmissible de l'état
quant au respect de la liberté de
circulation les long des plages une
situation est aggravée par l'érosion la
martinique rétrécie à vue d'oeil avec
par endroits 35 mètres de recul décote
en dix ans face à des troupes public qui
risque de s'aggraver
la responsabilité de l'état est engagée
non l'application de la loi littoral de
86 qui est store de servitude de passage
non application l'article 27 de la loi
d'octobre 2015 kioua le transfert de la
gestion des 50 pas aux collectivité de
martinique et de guadeloupe pas
d'approbation des documents stratégiques
ni de délimitation des terrains
concernés
pas de moyens financiers identifier
alors monsieur le premier ministre
j'ai deux questions et une suggestion
pouvez vous nous indiquer un nouvel
agenda en vue de respecter des
obligations de l'état
quand jugerez vous utile de donner un
vrai sens en notion de subsidiarité et
de différenciation dans ce pays à cet
égard la philosophie humaniste
émancipatrice d'aimé césaire peut être
une source d'inspiration
quand usure et vous de cette aspiration
pour sortir ce pays du première de leur
léthargie actuelle et de leurs
déresponsabilisation structurelles merci
monsieur le député la parole à madame
annick girardin ministre d outre-mer
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
serge letchimy
alors oui la règle des 50 pas
géométriques c'est environ 80 mètres
pour l'information de tous sur le
littoral dans les départements
d'outre-mer est une des plus anciennes
règles du droit français
cette bande en 1955 elle est devenue
domaine privé de l'état
et puis par la suite en 86 en 1986 on a
créé les agences des 50 pas des
établissements publics bien sûr de
l'état ces agences en depuis cette
époque en charge de régulariser des
occupations sans titre des terrains et
je le rappelle elle doit s'appliquer
bien sûr à tous alors je sais que ça
fait débat actuellement en martinique et
je sais effectivement qu'il faut
absolument qu'on arrive à traiter tous
ces sujets parce que de nombreuses
familles en depuis des générations pour
des raisons historiques des habitations
sur le littoral c'est régularisation et
peut-être fait au cas par cas bien sûr
en continuité d'urbanisation locale mais
elles peuvent pas être faites
quand on est dans une zone à risques
naturels ou encore d'intérêt écologique
majeure alors l'érosion du trait de côte
vous en avez parler monsieur le député a
eu pour conséquence de rendre impossible
l'accès à pied à certaines plages en
martinique alors il faut effectivement
qu'on soit dans l'action il faut qu'on
apporte une réponse une double réponse
j'aurais tendance à dire droit propriété
et en même temps libre passage
alors là où je vous rejoins c'est
qu'effectivement à votre initiative en
il a été décidé de transférer ses
agences aux collectivités territoriales
d'outre-mer
il ya eu quatre ans eh bien ça n'a pas
été fait il ya toujours eu beaucoup de
bonnes raisons pour pas le faire mais
quand je regarde bien le dossier
ces raisons elles sont pas valables et
vous avez raison chacun doit prendre ses
responsabilités et j'ai proposé et nous
ferons avec mes collègues françois de
rugy et jacqueline bourg ou de faire une
proposition dans le futur projet de loi
risque naturel outre-mer